compagnies aériennes cherchent aéroports
fermés pour entreposer ses avion qui ne
vole plus la compagnie american airlines
a trouvé l'aéroport de taussat en
oklahoma
pour garder ses appareils en bon état
dans un climat sec
en attendant en attendant quoi personne
ne sait les compagnies qui vole encore
le fonds pour rapatrier les touristes
air canada a mises à pied quinze mille
employés pour air transat c'est 70 pour
cent de sa main-d'oeuvre welch est enfin
supprimer 6000 900 emplois sur 14000
pour l'instant l'arrêt presque universel
du transport aérien va coûter de plus en
plus cher c'est du moins ce que prévoit
l'iata l'association internationale des
transporteurs aériens
son président alexandre de juniac avait
prévu un manque à gagner de 113
milliards de dollars pour ses 290
membres qui représentent 82% du
transport aérien mondial
il a révisé ses chiffres cela coûtera
probablement 252 milliards de dollars
les gouvernements doivent agir vite et
fort maintenant tout fort gosse une zone
africaine de natcho or l'industrie
ce oui ni de goldman sachs tremblay n
cochlée elle n'a
[Musique]
des grandes compagnies américaines ont
déjà estimé leurs besoins plus de 50
milliards de dollars
ils ont été vite entendue par le
président troc et son secrétaire au
trésor stephen nothin l'industrie sera
contente il y aura de l'aide c'est
acquis mais sous quelle forme
le congrès américain sera réticent à
donner de l'argent à des compagnies qui
au temps récent des vaches grasses
dépensé gros bénéfices dans des rachats
d'actions ou des dividendes aux
actionnaires
en négligeant d'améliorer le sort de ses
employés ou de ses passagers on parlera
de prêts plutôt que de subventions même
réticence probable pour boeing
si elle réclame de l'aide ces 737 max
sont encore cloués au sol et lui coûte
après les écrasements de lionhead
ethiopian plus de 12 milliards de
dollars
bon il prévoit en plus des reports de
commandes de compagnies aériennes la
production de gros porteurs à c'est un
taux a été mis sur pause
au canada bombardier suspend toute sa
production pendant un mois il y aura de
la consolidation comme on dit dans les
affaires ce qui veut dire des
disparitions de compagnie probablement
parmi les plus faibles
jean michel leprince radio-canada à
montréal